I find meetings of greater
than or equal to eight people,
far less productive than smaller groups.
Even with stroke,
with a structured action oriented agenda.
Is there a maximum amount of people
you'd involve in a strategic or tactical
planning group?
I don't think,
I don't think there is a massive amount.
I think it just has to be
controlled and you've got to have,
you've got to have some decentralized
command or people understand if there's
just a bunch of people in a meeting and
everyone's kind of speaking in, in turn,
um, and talking over each other,
you're not gonna get anything done.
So you got to have, there's got
to be one leader who's run that.
There's gotta be some, some,
you know, some other, uh,
uh, subordinate leaders that,
uh,
and,
and one person's got to drive that
meeting and make sure that when someone
starts going down a rabbit hole,
okay,
you guys have a sidebar
conversation afterwards.
Let's keep this meeting focused and less.
And ultimately the decision maker who
can focus the team on a single course of
action, get her by behind them. I agree.
And there's certainly times where you
can bring too many people in to try and
figure something out. I mean,
that can certainly happen. And we,
we have the good idea fairies that keep
coming around with their good ideas and,
and well, what if we did
this? I wonder if we did that.
There's also an interesting dynamic that
you just pointed out that ties into a
question that we had earlier or something
that we were talking about earlier,
which is,
okay,
so let's say we have a meeting and
there's 15 people in that meeting.
If the leader of that meeting,
then we'll say steps down into
the position of being the,
the director of the meeting itself.
Guess what he's doing the whole time
he's talking, he's pulling things,
he's good and what he's
doing while he's doing that,
as he's getting in the
weeds of what's going on.
So as he's getting in the
weeds of what's going on,
he's losing the strategic vision.
And so if there's 20 people in a meeting
and you as the leader are going, okay,
what do you think? What do you think?
What are you thinking? Hey, no,
let's get it refocused. When you're
doing all that traffic copping,
you're actually losing
your strategic altitude.
You're not going to be able to see
and make a good clear decision.
So if there's 30 40 50
people in a meeting,
and you as the leader get down in the
weeds and get down in the trenches and you
start throwing down with everyone, well
it's not gonna take very long. We'll,
you're just, you're just one of the
troops and you don't see anything.
Whereas if you let,
let one of the other leaders let one of
the subordinate leaders let them step up
and let them start to do their thing,
let them do the direction of the meeting.
And you might even tell him, hey, run this
meeting. I would do that. I'd be like,
Hey,
you run this meeting.
And then you let them get in there in the
trenches and let them try and sort out
ideas.
And they,
their mind gets filled with a bunch of
crap and meanwhile you're in the meeting,
you're just not running it.
So there's a big difference between
running the meeting and overseeing the
meeting or being in the meeting or
being the leading leader of a meeting.
So if we're going through a
kill house or if we're going,
if we're going through a kill
house, that's a good example,
which is, you know, the,
with the building with a bunch
of rooms in it, if as the leader,
you don't say, Hey, I'm gonna run this
kill house. I'm not gonna, I'm not,
I'm not going to direct the movement
through the kill house because then guess
what you're doing, you're directing
the movement through the kill house.
What you want to do is take
a step back and say, Hey,
you third, fourth, fifth,
and the chain of command.
You run this kill house, you run the
train, and now that guy goes, okay, cool,
I got it. And now while he's
running the train, doing the work,
you're stepped back at altitude,
you can see what's going on,
you can hear the frustration,
you can hear shots fired,
you know where people are moving, then
you become, you are the real leader.
So same thing at a meeting.
If the dynamics of the meeting or you
get more than 10 people, 15 people,
and what you're doing is you're
down there directing traffic,
it's going to be really
problematic for you.
If you have a meeting with 15 or 20
people and you tell someone else to direct
the meeting and run the meeting and you
take a step up and you simply observe,
you're going to have a better time
feeling like the meeting is effective
and you will get the benefit of hearing
all these different voices,
which is good,
which is good to hear all these different
opinions and voices and be able to
pick through and sort through and that's
going to give you more benefit than a,
you know what I get,
there's too much going on in this meeting.
Only give me two people and we'll make
the decisions. Well, there's some people,
number of number, the six person,
that person had a good input, right?
The 12th person might've had some good
input. So again, is there balance? Yes.
Are there certain decisions that you
kind of need to take and really dive down
and with a small group?
Absolutely,
but is it good sometimes to let things
air out and let someone run a meeting and
you listen and you learn kind of what
the overall atmosphere because of the
situation are? Absolutely.
That's my answer.
I think it's a great one. It helps people.
It helps people listen to you as well.
Right?
I mean if,
if you're the boss and you're just sitting
back and you're not saying anything
and then all of a sudden you're like, hey
guys, we're getting way off topic here.
This is what we need to do. Here's
the address we need to go. Got It.
Everyone's back on track. Whereas if
you're in the middle of it, then yeah,
people are just automatically
kind of doing. There is,
I'm sure you've said this before and
I know we talked about earlier too,
but like when I would say something on
the radio and task unit bruiser when I
would say like a legitimate thing,
Manny would happen if I got on and said
everyone get to building 34 now people
would go and I,
one of my favorite things to do,
one of my favorite conversations to have
on the radio with with either you or
stoner was like I remember you'd
be like, you'd say, Hey Jocko,
we've got another mover or where I want
to take down building 34 and I'd come up
and go do it.
But that was all I'd ever set to be
like do it just like go because I'm not
trying to talk. Right. I got these
guys, got their situations handled.
Hey he's going outside of it.
Something that we planned. Hey Jack,
I want to build a move to building 34
and take that thing down. Do it. Nah.
Well why do you want to do that?
You know why he wants to do it?
Cause he's got a good reason.
He's not me that because it's a fantasy
that he thinks it's going to be cool. No,
there's a reason.
And he'll explain that to me later.
And if it was something where
he's like, I want to, you know,
start doing jumping jacks out here,
then I might ask why,
because that doesn't make much sense
to me. But to say, hey, we're gonna,
we're gonna hit building 34 as well.
What if we were doing burpees with Dell?
Would that make more sense?
That makes a little more sense,
a little more sense than jumping jacks.
Look that that absolutely worked.
It worked for us. When you, when you said
something over the radio, like got it.
We're good. Like it is the decision made
everyone's on board. And uh, I think it's,
it's something that, um, you've got
to, you've got to focus on what,
like when a leader talks, it should
matter. And I think you can be,
you gotta be really careful about that.
And I've certainly been achieved violator
that of like going off to dip too many
different directions, but, um, that,
that you did extremely well tasking at
bruiser and it works on every leader
should be very conscious of them. Yeah.
The less you talk, the more people listen.